all right what's up guys my name is
kim and we're here at cal anderson park
aka chop aka chaz
i'm just here to soak in the energy and
become one of the people
let's go check it out
so over here you can see the illuminati
it's all about control and mind control
over here
conspiracy is real pick it up
uh over here we have a condominium
complex being set up it's uh very
reminiscent of
gentrification so it's just part of the
system it's just
going downtown
and uh over here we have a light post
[Music]
you know every protest is centered
around a central location
in china you had
egypt
um
very cool thing to do is have an
occupied place
that anytime anyone wants to uh
go to a protest they have a place now
you need two things to meet up with
people a time and a place
if you have the place down and the time
is flexible
and now we have uh a place so
people can have a place where they can
meet whenever they feel a little
protesty which is a legitimate feeling
to have
we should all feel a little protesting
now because the
coronavirus really threw a brick into
the economy and made us realize how
fragile this whole thing
is and uh
we we demand that the government take
care of its people a little bit better
so it's a good time to make your voice
heard and try to get out there and
let people know that uh we're sick of it
and we want uh we want a better world
this is the perfect
way to do it is have a central plate
that we can all beat up and do it at
and then it's trump tras there's a crow
right here look at that crow it's full
of antarctic energy
it doesn't give a [ __ ]
it's so close to us and it's just
chilling because it feels
the the freedom of the people it feels
that energy
is one power to you crow
that's an anarchic crowd that's antifa
right there
that crow is embodying antifa we are all
that crow
we are all crowish right now power to
the crows
that's a badass crow
sometimes there's water here
anarchy
um
we don't throw things away because we
are the trash
um i think that
seattle and portland and the northwest
in general is full of
freedom energy because we're far away we
never feel involved in anything
like when the mariners won 116 games did
we get a sportscenter clip
not really no one really cared about it
it's all about the major cities and no
one really
cares about us so if you don't care
about us we'll do whatever the [ __ ] we
want
and i think that's cool uh you need to
you need a seattle
just like you needed texas you can't
just all be texas
you need a little liberalism or else
you're gonna turn into goddamn
mississippi
you know you'd balance it out you you
have a texas you need a seattle you
can't just have all texas joe rogan
we need a little liberalism in the world
like obama you had like that red and
blue
and with trump you just have it's like
obama's picture but with
uh trump is just like the words just
typography
it's an art form but not as complex
we got some tents over here it's
beautiful tenting
um i think uh the tent is beautiful
but it's a central location it's a good
thing you're wearing boots
[Music]
hey what's up guys this guy and i are
here just
chilling and hanging out with nobody two
elbows
two of us hit everybody run up get up
one more punch punch forward
hooks uppercut
go forward three times world war one
world war
two
[Laughter]
red cross
you can talk to anybody it makes you
sweet i gotta educate you
can you real water fountain not work
oh good thank you for showing me the
weight
thank you probably doesn't work
but uh yeah we got three jrs so i can't
really complain
and punching advice yes we did a little
self-defense right there
this is the garden i just think there
was a
raptors in four days i think there was a
garden in
downtown right in chinatown
coming up get ready for that just put
that in your calendar
mark it down
beautiful
get it right what are you gonna do
it's like i'm just one person here and
chopped chaz i don't wanna
make a big stink about my intensity this
is a cool area i used to uh come over
here and
throw footballs
there's a little playground for your
little antifa anarchist children
you uh have some little rugrats
that need a little uh
anti-authoritarianism installed into
them this perfect place
for them to swing around and you'll [ __ ]
the police
got some shoes right there
there's like a mix between uh camp or
hippies and the yuppie playground they
have the masters here
like hey we want kids to swing around
but
we also want justice so it's like a
combination of both
just what's going on here
got some anti-skateboarding
architecture
this is still you know there might be a
lot of uh
vagrants and homeless but the kids are
yeah they respect the playground
they didn't take away the kids uteruses
as long as you're gonna get hysterectomy
at the border
survive that you can bring your kids
here
trump it looks like he's gonna get voted
out i uh
go on this betting website where they'll
show you the odds and
find it's in the lead but biden is a
very
uh middle-of-the-road figure this is how
we
we nominated biden because we're trying
to appeal to the republican
we don't no one in the democrats really
like biden it's
what we're trying to do to get you on
board with us this is our sacrifice
to you so it's like come on
if we really wanted to do what we wanted
to do we would have gotten bernie
or someone even more crazy
and uh we're kind of appealed to you so
that's why
we went with this crazy here
i [ __ ] love you you know
you know so this is
i appreciate it uh so i used to come
here
when i was a child and just swing around
on the floor
now we're here at the uh yuppies this is
where you can play flag football
you can play ultimate ultimate frisbee
right here
you can uh
that's where you come the real grass is
too dirty
and the uh artificial turf is just dead
enough
and flat enough for you to play around
you want to check out the garden
what are you doing with the jolly
rancher i'm not gonna eat it really
i don't go in for sweets unless it's
cake or like ice cream
here is the garden i want to tread
lightly just let everyone know that i'm
not here
to uh destroy their garden
i'm not here to eat their sunflowers i'm
just here to observe
sort of soak it all in
a lot of uh sudden mood that's going on
over there
so this is a little beautiful area they
got some water
right there some resistance water
i think your thumb is touching the
bottom of it
hold it oh yeah you got it
and if all this is way too hippy and way
too
freaky for you there's way too much
freedom
over here the astroturf area
where everything is in straight lines
and you can
draw a circle around yourself and just
sort of stratify yourself like you're in
the suburbs
this is like the freedom zone and if you
like the suburbs
you've got the suburbs for you right
here
definitely for everyone here in
i was seattle running over here once and
some guy was like godzilla
godzilla i was like oh my god they were
racist to me i'm so
angry and then i drove past the same
kids that y'all godzilla at me because
i'm asian
and i'm running away from something and
uh i drove by them and i was like go get
a bank account
i totally own them dude radical
do you own them with the p the p yes
um yeah i pound them
i palm them to a pawn shop
to be in this it's a cal anderson park
so now we're here in the safe section
where a white man can be a white man
so even if you're you know uh black the
blue
trump supporter there's an area for you
right here
in the middle of this park you can be
white
and safe here you can be safe and white
anywhere but if you want to be that here
that's possible too
so we can just do some yoga just sit
down get to know each other
have a good time
a little tree post but i think
uh the essence of it this is all about
freedom and love and uh it's a good
place
and we should honor and respect it and i
think that
uh it's a good place and i think it's
what it stands for is good
like i just walked around in it and no
one attacked me and they respected the
fact that i was here
and they weren't like you're recording
what are you doing that for
they didn't try to deprive me of freedom
uh
they let me be me and be weird so as
long as i can be me
i mean i'm just one test you gotta come
here and
try to be you here maybe if you're not a
nerdy asian dude they're kind of meaty
but i'm sort of harmless looking like
i'm wearing really soft clothes i feel
really soft right now
but um
it's good to be here and um
i think it's uh it's sad that that uh
cop ran over a dude's head with the bike
i think that was uncalled for
and i think that uh we should really not
run over people's heads with
uh bike tires i think that's that's not
okay
anyways let's uh turn the camera around
see what's behind the camera
so what brings you out to capitol hill
today
uh this sexy asian dude i'm having sex
with
i didn't say who it was oh you're
having sex with the sexy asian dude
that's not me
i don't know sunshine you
jazz we're looking for the um
the really cool black lives matter
painted thing on the ground but it's
gone
i kind of want to go look at it and see
if we can see its vestiges
what do you think i think it's there
really
let's go look they said they were gonna
do it
i think it's uh wonderful over here
i think that you know you can play
baseball the most white of sports
out here i mean you can't play
basketball maybe we should have gone
over to that area
of the park they take the hoops out they
took the rims off the backboard
of the basketball and i think that's a
little racist
but it's hard to imagine that
cops want to shut this down
never forget how
i mean it's all fun and games now but
this is where jolene
kent got a flashbang grenade tossed at
her
tossed on her right there
and a lot of pain happened right here um
she was right by that fence she's an nbc
reporter
and the cops flashbanged her so you know
they're kind of
indiscriminate and a lot of people were
gassed over there
and a lot of windows were broken over
there so it's not a
it's not all fun and games there's a lot
of pain over here and
a lot of it was perpetrated by the cops
on civilians i'm sure the protesters
were violent too
but it's usually to uh windows
it's not really to people
i think uh i think i think hurting
people is way worse and
way more violent than breaking windows
i think that you should flash bang me
later
um i mean i am a quite a premature
ejaculator
i tried to last as long as possible but
sometimes
this can't help but i can't help myself
around you
just gotta explode
very good [ __ ] as quick as
possible
[Applause]
[Music]
fascism they should have spelled it
let's see